russia's lower House of Parliament
passed a new Bill that authorities to
confiscate Property of any spreading
false Information the army measure also
apply to those Guilty of disc The Armed
Forces those Calling for sanctions
Against Russia and those Found Guilty
extremist
Activity does not to include Real Estate
Among the asss that
can
die for our country for our country for their
families Why is there no law that protects
them Why is there no law that punishes
the scoundrels
who stick a knife in the back of our
officers Why is there no law that would
punish them so that it would not be possible,
many of them left for  the borders of the
state and from there they pour dirt. How
can one influence this today?
Confiscation
of property has appeared because the property remains here;
palaces; business; and much more; those who
look
to the United States of America as an example
would have long ago already had those who
criticize the country in such a
situation in connection with  I
admit to our judicial system imperfectly and we all
understand this, as in any
country, innocent people can fall under this,
so any
similarity
still
deprives a person of his rights and,
again, it’s difficult to get to the truth here.
Well, I think that discrediting the army
is more  moral damage to the country than
physical and as a result of this, it’s more likely
criminal liability or
administrative or some kind of
restriction, yes, perhaps for a person, if he
is a public figure, then restrictions on
speaking, that’s all, but if it
concerns property, I think no, this is
somehow incorrect a little Well  property is
usually taken for debts for
discrediting Well, there may be criminal
liability but not property liability. Well,
I think that firstly you need to comply with the
laws. Whatever they would be if you live
in this
state, it’s a difficult question because
if you broke the law, there
must be some
consequences  That is, I proceed from
this if you live on the territory of this
state You must comply with its
laws, first of all you are a citizen
Visitor Tourist Expat and so on I am
more inclined to answer no than yes, after all,
discrediting the army is not
something worth taking away property for
after all, property is a material
benefit for which a person has been saving for years, or
maybe decades,
and there is no point in this
discrediting the army; term;
criminal case; prison; but not confiscation
of property